il semble que le mythe de l'ascenseur
social est vécu 13 % seulement des
étudiants en classes préparatoires des
grandes écoles sont issus des milieux
populaires
un rapport rendu public aujourd'hui par
le sénat dénonce à la fois l'élitisme du
système et son coût pour tenter d'y
remédier science pauvres a mis en place
il ya sept ans une filière pour les
élèves issus de lycées et de zones
d'éducation prioritaire cécile la ronce
philippe rey leïla a surmonté sa peur
elle vient d'intégrer sciences pauvres
sans le programme égalité des chances
elle n'aurait jamais osé prétendre
franchir les portes d'une grande école
pourtant elle a largement niveau un bac
s avec mention bien aux poches décroché
dans un lycée de zone d'éducation
prioritaire
je n'aurais pas pensé à intégrer
sciences po car on voit son scoop
comme l'école des élites on se dit que
souviens pas avec un certain bagage de
la part
ce n'est pas ici d'un certain milieu on
se sent sur un petit peu on n'imagine
pas qu'on puisse en fait être
capable de suivre normalement c'est les
cours à sciences po d'en sortir diplômée
leïla a intégré l'institut d'études
politiques en passant un concours
spécifique destiné aux élèves de zep
basé sur le contrôle continu en
terminale sciences po paris a été la
première école attentes et la
discrimination positive
ce dispositif mis en place en 2001
permet de détecter des élèves brillants
de leur donner leur chance comme
sallèles qui suit les cours de quatrième
année en france des années 60 quand il
voit aujourd'hui son fils est entré dans
une grande école sont cherchées pour lui
c'est une fierté pour moi vous dire tous
les efforts qu'il a faits tous les
efforts qu'il a effectués durant toute
cette ou ces loups en france ils sont
enfin enfin j'essaie de récompenses et
de remercier par sa part mon travail et
par une petite réussite qui est comparé
à la sienne et encore aujourd'hui à
sciences po 95 étudiants bénéficient de
ce programme égalité des chances
d'autres établissements prestigieux
comme hec ou le lycée henri iv propose
désormais des classes préparatoires
destinées aux élèves issus des milieux
défavorisés des dispositifs qui
mériterait selon un rapport sénatorial
d'être étendu à l'ensemble du territoire
français je vous en parle